i don't think that's the same as the
hard problem or
or the existence of phenomenal
consciousness because you can build an
ai system and you correct me if i'm
wrong that like
we'll pass a turing test in terms of
demonstrating the qualities of like uh
a sense of self it will talk as if
there's a self and there's probably a
certain like
algorithm or whatever
like computational like you know scaling
up of computations that results and
somehow
and i think this is the argument with
with humans with some have
speculated this why do we have this
illusion of the self that's that's
evolved that
and we might find this with ai that like
it works
you know having a sense of self or
in that state it wrong incorrectly like
acting
as if there is a an agent
at play and dim behaviorally acting like
you know there is a there is a self that
might kind of work
and so you can program a computer or a
robot
um to basically demonstrate have an
algorithm like that and demonstrate that
type of behavior and i
think that's completely silent on
whether there's an actual experience
inside there
i've been um struggling to find the
right words and how i feel about that
whole thing
but uh because i've said it poorly
before
i've before said that there's no
difference between the appearance
and the actual existence of
consciousness or intelligence or any of
that
what i really mean is
the the more the appearance starts to be
look like the thing the more there's
this area where it's like
i don't think i don't
our whole idea of what is real
and what is just an illusion is um
not the right way to think about it so
the whole idea is like if you create a
system
that looks like it's having fun the more
it's realistically able to portray
itself as having
fun like there's a certain gray area
which it's the system is having fun uh
and say with intelligence same with
consciousness and we humans want to
simplify like it feels like the way we
simplify the existence
and the illusion of something uh is
is uh missing the whole truth of the
nature of reality which we're not yet
able to understand like it's the one
percent we only understand one percent
currently so we don't have the right
uh physics to talk about things we don't
have the right science to talk about
things but
to me like the um uh
faking it and actually it being true
is um
the the difference is much smaller than
humans would like to imagine
that's my intuition but philosophers
hate that because
and uh guess what it's philosophers what
have you actually built
uh so like to me is that's the
difference between philosophy and
engineering
it feels like if we push the creation
the engineering
like fake it until you make it all the
way which is like fake consciousness
until you realize holy crap this thing
is conscious
fake intelligence until you realize holy
crap this is intelligence
and from the my curiosity with
psychedelics
and just neurobiology neuroscience
is like it feels i'm i love the armchair
i love sitting in that armchair because
it feels like at a certain point you're
going to think about this problem
and there's going to be an aha moment
like that's what the armchair does
sometimes science prevents you from
really thinking
right wait like it's really simple
there's something really simple like
there's some that could be
some dance of chemicals that were
totally unaware of not from
not from aspects of like which chemicals
to combine
with which biological architectures but
more like
we were thinking of it completely wrong
that uh just
out of the blue like maybe the human
mind is just like
a radio that tunes into some other
medium where consciousness actually
exists like those uh weird sort of
hypothetical like maybe we're just
thinking about the human mind
totally wrong maybe there's no such
thing as individual
intelligence maybe it is all collective
intelligence between humans
like maybe the intelligence is possessed
in the communication
of language between minds and then in
fact consciousness is a property of that
language
versus a property of the individual
minds and somehow the
neurotransmitters will be able to
connect to that so uh
then ai systems can join that common
collective intelligence that common
language
you know like just thinking completely
outside of the box i just said a bunch
of crazy things
i don't know but but thinking outside
the box uh
and there's something about subtle
manipulation of the chemicals of the
brain
which feels like the best
or one of the great chances of the
scientific
process leading us to an actual
understanding of the hard problem
you